it's in all different forms of pastries
okay wait a minute wait a minute really
no hold on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you uh you were different
[Music]
this is John Favreau and Pedro Pascal
and this is snack Wars Chile versus the
us something you'll never hear at the
World Cup
it's possible is it yeah I think so not
in the final no probably not Chile
didn't do so well cut that
we're doing Chile U.S because you're a
Yankee
Gringo uh according to my enormous
family and uh and here we go
um
we're supposed to guess if this is cake
or not or is that a different show so
this is a very fast this would be like
this is a wafery
uh it's not even really a chocolate bar
this is a Reese's
this is the large format this is the
IMAX version of the races uh it's a big
cup
this is uh you've seen these before
I don't have to tried it I I I will have
some but there's no competition for me
oh really super great job that much
better no this is this is my favorite uh
oh really chocolate bar well get ready
to have a case of a trip to you sorry
Chile
are you a fan of the Mini version or do
you like the the IMAX version
well I like the IMAX or even because
there's more peanut butter a little bit
of a KitKat thing going on here they're
pretty good so I'd say I'd say I would
go with the uh Reese's though I would
give Reese's for me
rhesus beats all for me we've started
too high okay so we were to go but down
ET was right exactly
this one I know what this is I grew up
with these this is McDonald's isn't it
and I haven't had one but we're having
McDonald's in the UK which isn't the
same this whole thing is a fraud
oh wait a minute these are empanadas
so tell me about this this is just meat
and caramelized onion and some olives
and some delicious especially if you got
it in Chile because the bread there
we've got some um dipping sauce for you
there thing
I grew up on these I mean first of all I
have to say I need you to get the round
here yeah first of all how dare you
empanadas versus a quarter pounder with
cheese no
well they're very different than um
empanadas you get in Argentina oh how's
that
it's the the size the way that they're
made
the combination of meat and potatoes and
the olive black olives and onions and
these are good where'd you get these I'm
actually putting those until
the chili and padding spin I'll take
this somebody put this in my room
you learned a film set never is always
like oh the first I get to eat pizza in
the scene yeah and then by the afternoon
so I presume that there's a point for
chile
lovely love it although the quarter
pounder right it is yummy I do like it
is that your favorite McDonald's burger
yeah I think the quarter pounder with
cheese definitely favorite the best of
them the best of the bunch I'm a I'm a
fish fillet man myself
fish is it Filet-O-Fish it's not even
fish fillet no it's a filet fish I guess
that gave me away
Mars cookies this is not from is this is
this uh America is this supposed to be
the US oh yes
now what's this ah this is Cookie so
this is a Dulce so what you would say is
dulce de leche but in Chile it's and
that's the condensed milk if you boil it
for eight hours
there's no you don't have to try the
Mars cookies
like what baby Yoda was eating in there
yeah
the black step is not blue oh man it is
really nostalgic
very sweet
we do sweets very well no it's really
good yeah
not too sweet actually you know
the sweets
or diabolical and cheetah especially
when it comes to my pride and it's part
of everything you can have it for
breakfast you can spread it's like it's
not it's it's you put it on toast it's
in all different forms of pastries okay
wait a minute wait a minute really no
hold on
no you got this one
you uh you weren't there for me
no this is no this one this one's a
winner this one's almost two points yeah
yeah this gets two points this gets a
negative one
oh now we're talking oh no you can't do
me you can't do me Five Guys oh yeah
strawberry milkshake from Five Guys
and a vanilla shake from Chile so it's a
banana
sign if you said it's vanilla that's
banana yeah it's banana with uh
electrical Ninja
hmm
they're both good um
I gotta go with this one this is the
strawberry one
it's uh it's special
but this isn't this is it this wasn't
this isn't this is a disqualification
because it would be better if we were in
Chile
ah
ah there we go oh peanut butter peanut
butter and jelly versus what do you got
what is this I want is this how is this
Balta it's avocado
so it's maricetta huh which is it is a
breakfast thing and I suppose that would
be a bra or a tea thing
[Music]
or breakfast this is my favorite you
guys are doing well
what's this bread is this a special this
is what I get that this is really really
good bread they make great bread and
Chile
um and uh you get it fresh and it's
really just
a healthy snack
so basically all you do you just mash up
the avocado you put salt in olive oil
this one's gonna be tough though because
I gotta say yeah
peanut butter and jelly I mean it's not
as flashy
it's what I grew up with peanut butter
is really good I know I would go for
that more just because of
my childhood there's no comparison for
me
I mean and that's okay I'll give it you
know what I'll give you this one because
no no because I think that is probably
better quality I'm very impressed though
with the Chilean food I've never had any
of that except empanadas we've got good
snacks you know and I and I
underestimate how good the snacks are
awesome nice can we send this to my room
again
congratulations thank you very much
Chile in the US has finally amended
their relationship
it's too bad it's not UK snacks because
I love how people in the UK think that
they have good snacks
I'm Australian shots fired
what's your stance on Mama
I mean this is how it sounds Mama it's
not glamorous
these kitchens have got a disaster this
is not this is not cooking uh oh my God
you call this right tattoo